babymoov ilona mickey mouse also what you
exactly it's very good first de
again be serious cube and de gorges
curcio cola maya tenth time playa
mega take off in the values ​​turns
simili program by sheena 3 your
orientation is
[Music]
hello i am  peter
in the early 2000s
europe was rocked by a number of
swords plane crashes in august
2000 and paint
spills helios a flight 522 crashed on
a flight between cyprus and prague
121 passengers died after
the accident week the airline
systematically
had safety regulations  ignored
it is my job to make sure
something like this can never happen again
i am geert if an
airline does
not comply with international
safety rules
i immediately alert the
aviation authorities
of all countries planting the aircraft
to bridge
if yes no yes yes nice teams of the  braking
style know there technical curry with
pineapple from children's jury becomes the remote work
can be winners it king's
landing had to get your scanner
barely looked down but I did
stand that's already inspect cartoon
printing in our industry
[Music]
hi him jeroen he  helps managers that your
central database with a will so far
cross inspections found in the 21 red
always
but in terms of luxury to analyze the and wine
finding smash music from respect is
my career that guy fine resume line the
solid keel and who participate always
confused skries  how bits am in them
line from the job in scars
gaming that en gaza that you have to i
ballistic this is critic bent there was
an honor that i correct i think so yeah
mega wasn't format deny
but green legolas unlearned
that no juices there is that  ain't action
red out there where this time two
cars force
polly throw swiping is and there
is the post office manager inside hot
can in my smarter winner with us can
i year who plant articles and bella
thorne is
[Music]
medical information
it's racists how crysis 2
shift
something with a
program [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]